Hey, everybody. Welcome to
the data science hangout.
Hope you all had a nice
Thanksgiving holiday if you
celebrated or a nice week,
regardless, last week.
If this is your first
time joining us today,
so nice to meet
you. I'm Rachel.
I lead customer
marketing at Posit.
If this is your first hangout,
say hi in the chat because
we'd love to welcome you in,
especially anybody joining
for the first time.
The hangout is our open space
to chat about data science
leadership, questions
you're facing,
and getting to hear what's
going on in the world of data
across different industries.
And so we're here
every Thursday
at the same time, same
place, unless it's a holiday.
If you're watching this
recording on YouTube later,
and you wanna join a slide,
there'll be a link to add
it to your calendar in the
description below.
At the data science thing out,
we're all dedicated to making
a welcoming environment for everybody.
So we love to hear from
everyone no matter your years
of experience, titles, industry, or
languages that you work in.
Totally okay to
just listen in here.
But there's also three ways you
can jump in and ask questions
or provide your own
perspective too.
So you could raise
your hand on Zoom,
and I'll keep an eye out here.
You could put questions
in the Zoom chat.
And if it's something that
you want me to read Instead,
you could put a little
star next to it,
and I'll know to
read that for you.
But we also have a slide a
link too so you can ask questions anonymously.
But with all that,
thank you so much for spending
your Thursday with us.
I'm so excited to be joined
by my cohost today. Laura Gas,
data science, and
analytics manager at USO.
And Laura,
love to have you introduce
yourself and maybe share a
little bit about your role and something
you like to do outside of work.
Yeah. So, hi, everyone. Thanks
for having me here, Stan.
So my role right now, I
work in the the development operation
side. So, basically,
it's fundraising data.
And, like, I'd say,
ninety five percent
of nonprofit organizations
our data is kind of everywhere and
kind of a little bit of a
mess. And as happens
with siloed information
may or siloed organizations may be
what we call one thing in
one database is not
the same in the other.
So bringing together all
of these different components,
and we have multiple databases
for incoming gift and making
them all talk together. To
get at the end of the day,
the question is how much money
did we raise this month and
from whom? And it seems
like an easy question,
but just like how many clients
do we have in our organization.
It's usually more difficult
than, and then you should.
Then you think it
should be. And so,
for those that don't know
USO as United Services
Organization, do you watch
the movie White Christmas,
Bob Hope sings at one of those
We provide services for
us currently serving military
members and their family.
And,
so that's what I do for my job.
My background actually
is an epidemiologist.
But in twenty twenty, I stepped
away from that for a bit.
And, the thing I like to
do outside of this is,
outside of my work is
probably running marathons or playing
darts. So those are
my two fun fun things.
Is awesome. Where's your
favorite marathon location?
I love Chicago marathon. It's just
it's big but not too big.
It's not New York big.
Fifty thousand people is
too many people from that.
Thirty thousand is plenty.
And then it's always got
great weather and amazing crowds. So
Nice. I love it.
Well, thank you so much
Laura for joining us here.
I get to start out with some
of the questions while we wait for
everything, everybody to,
weigh in with their questions.
But I know
you gave a great talk
at deposit conference on design and
I'd love to hear a little bit
from you about that. Like,
what is one of your favorite
lessons you like to share with
people about data visualization
and information design.
Yeah. So,
my talk was exactly that.
It's kind of my lessons learned
and trying to think about how
humans think when you're
creating a report or a data
visualization or even a
Excel file, just a table.
Because throughout
my career, and again,
I've worked many careers as
an epidemiologist for several
different countries.
The common thing I came across
was I thought I was saying something,
but someone else thought I
was saying something else.
And so the flexing
those empathy muscles or flexing
those stepping outside of
what you're seeing muscles was
one part of that. The other
part was I would have to
present both to, you know,
a minister of health who had
four and a half minutes for me.
And at the end of that
four and a half minutes,
they had to sign
off on a big spend,
but also convince their policy wonks
who wanted to see all of
the data within it.
And I had to do all of that
within that four minute window.
It's kind of bringing those
two things together and what I've
learned from that.
My favorite kind of instance of,
of of this, I guess,
was
oh, let's pick this one.
So we were working on a,
rapid response or rapid reporting
system for malaria in South Africa.
South Africa is almost to
the point of eliminating.
And so you get these,
like, little pops. Right?
So instead of countries
that have a lot,
where it's just always a lot,
and sometimes it's higher
and sometimes it's lower,
but it's always going on in
countries that are eliminating,
it's very, very,
very, very low.
And then it goes
off the charts,
and then you you react
and bring it back down,
and then it's a
little off the charts.
And the important thing to do
is when it starts to go up,
If you cut it off, then
it's gonna come back out right.
So you need to know really
quickly when you're starting to
approach that threshold where
everything's just gonna kinda
go off the rails
for a bit. And,
figuring out that whole system
and how to demonstrate that
this system that we'd spent a
lot of time and money based on,
like, sending nurses
sending SMSes.
Right? Because paper would
take months to get there.
Demonstrating that the system
that we only put in a few
sentinel sites was actually
gonna catch that threshold.
And while, you know,
I'm making this up,
the threshold would really be one
hundred cases in this large area,
we were able to say at
these two clinics based on all of
this past history, we're we
see this thresholds first there.
And so nine cases at that
clinic really is the problem.
And so how do you convince
people who are used to thinking
one hundred is the problem
that nine is the problem?
And so demonstrating these
these graphics one over the
other, this is what the
path looks like. Usually,
this is what the path looks
like at this first our sentinel stations,
so knowing that that's
happening in our central station,
and then tying that again
to the the economic impact of
letting it get here versus
cutting it off here.
So that whole story,
but putting those two visuals
together, we actually came
up with one single image,
which was those two lines where
you could see our sentinel
stations as as being
those those highlights.
So that was one of my
I was really excited that we were
able to nail that that
one picture to tell the whole
story, and then we
could keep talking.
But we wanted people to go, oh,
and then come with us on the
rest of it rather than go like,
charts, whatever. Just tell me when
I need to do stuff. So
it's my one good example I
can think of. That's great.
Thank you. I wanted to also
just give a shout out to your
new blog that you,
thank you hosted.
Because just when you were
mentioning, like, the story in
that, I was thinking of, like,
there's a line in that blog
post I share that says those
who tells the stories rule
the world, that you wrote.
And you talked about how,
like, we're wired to remember stories
better than a list of facts.
And so
thinking about like our own
presentations that we're
giving, how do you actually,
like, come up with the story
that people are
going to remember?
Yeah. Absolutely. So just a note
on the blog, I got COVID,
which is why I didn't there's
not a new one from last month.
So there are more coming.
They're just half written and I
for two weeks instead of doing
other work and I'm digging
myself out. So more are coming.
I just they're not there yet.
But talking about
humans as storytellers,
You don't remember
the bullet points.
You don't remember the numbers.
Well, few people remember the
numbers when you're given
a presentation. Right? You
remember, oh, yeah.
Last week, my coworker, Sam,
he gave that presentation
on that project,
and I remember the red
line went up. Right? Oh,
they must have been doing well.
I think he mentioned something
about them working with that
data field, and
it was going well,
and they solved something
with that other thing.
You're not remembering. It
went up fourteen percent.
You're not remembering he joined
it and on the thirty
first of twenty eighteen. That's
when the data type changes.
You might remember it. But
you're remembering the theme.
Right? And you remember that
Sam solved this problem.
You remember that Sam solved
this problem by talking to
Paul. You know, you're
remembering the the the meat of
it. And while you're hearing
that presentation from Sam, Sam
is connecting all the dots
for you so that you're brought
along in that story.
Each of those little story
points is supported by the
facts of we went up
fourteen percent.
It was December of
twenty eighteen. Those little factoids,
but really what you're doing
is carrying someone through a
story so you can say this
is the problem we started with.
This is where we ended up.
And anybody in your audience
should remember the gist of
your your story.
And then they'll have it in
their head when they need to
come back and solve a similar
problem or hire you to come in
and solve the problem for them.
So that could
that kind of idea.
But humans by nature
are storytellers.
We don't We don't necessarily
remember the pieces.
We remember an arc. And if you
could put your facts into an arc,
then you're you have
a better memory of it.
And if you think
you don't do arcs,
if you've ever written
an academic paper,
what is an introduction,
background methods, materials,
results and discussion.
It's introduction,
and then you have all the
components of a story,
the denouement, the conclusion.
Everything everything humans build
is kind of into that
bark, anything that
lasts works in there.
So that's kind of
where I've my blog,
my presentation are
sort of in those worlds.
I love this. And
I'm seeing a lot of,
reactions to this
in the chat here.
So I didn't wanna jump off this
topic if somebody had a a
specific follow-up question on
this too. Or stories
where it worked for you?
I always love you.
Yeah. Stories from others. Absolutely.
Okay. We'll give you
time to weigh in.
You could put you could
share them in the chat too.
But I did see a slide o
question or no. It wasn't slide
o. Let's see. I see you asked
a question. Do you wanna jump in?
Hi. Thanks. That's really
nice because I enjoy storytelling,
and I think science is
all about storytelling,
and how effectively do we
do that. So I guess, recently,
one of my relatives was
diagnosed with a neurodiversity
condition. And I was just
curious, like, how have you
incorporated or what kind of
tools have you incorporated in
your own version of
storytelling to really
accommodate for more neuro
diverse, individuals,
individuals who may have faced
stressed or trauma and don't
necessarily see the
data in the same way as,
someone, with a
different, neurological background?
Yeah. Absolutely. So I'll
take it kind of in two parts.
So one is the I have a family
member who was recently
diagnosed with a cancer,
and I was I'm this
person's patient advocate,
so I was reading the
documentation so as to not
stress this person.
And so from that
side of things,
I am always careful
to use warning symbols
in a very careful way. Right?
So think about the color red.
One of my organization's main
colors is red. I actively work
against using that color anywhere.
I don't need to go bad.
I will only want red because
we were in a western culture.
There are different colors
for different cultures,
but especially in in in the
western USC Canada EU type or
UK type situation. Red is bad.
Green is good. Blue is
cool. It's, you know, is relaxes
is is even is baseline. So I
am really careful to use those colors.
In this report for
my family member,
They use red as the heading
because red was one of their
organizational colors. And when
someone's going panicked, like,
oh my gosh, I have this
cancer diagnosis. This is scaring me.
Seeing that red color is gonna
connect to something deep
within their brain where they're gonna
worry why is that heading in red?
The heading in Red is
just telling you, like,
what the tests mean and how
they work. It's not bad.
I mean, the whole thing is bad.
If that that section shouldn't
be with some emotional tag
like red. Right? So I'm
really careful in using those.
Also symbols, you know, an
x symbol should mean no or
bad or don't. Right? A green
check should mean you've
already done this.
An empty box should be this
is a thing you have to do.
Right? And I've
developed, like,
consent forms for police
participate in our study. Same
kind of idea. If there's
a big warning for privacy sections,
I will put that in red if
I have a lot of color because I
want people to
go, oh, attention.
This could be bad. Right?
I want that attention.
So leveraging that color when
you need to invoke an emotion
is really important.
So that's kind of on
the one side for the
the the bad news type of
diagnostic diagnostic. But for, let's say,
maybe I had some neurodivergent
people in my audience or,
maybe my I've had a boss
who was on, autism spectrum
disorder. And would focus
on things and they go,
why are they focused? Oh, okay.
That person just is
just looking at that quadrant.
Right? Like, why are they
always look at that quadrant? Well,
one I started to realize
this person always looked at that
quadrant of a report.
So I started putting the main
information in that quadrant of the report.
So you know,
working with individuals is
easier than working with a
broad audience. But again,
when you're working at
that broad audience,
Basically, I assume I
I'm in a coding of
programming space.
The odds of someone being
neurodivergent in my audience
are reasonably high
at any given time.
I'm always trying to make
sure again I'm waiting waiting
information in any presentation in
the same way I don't want
to catch that person
might, you know,
this person's attention in the
wrong section first before I
tell them the thing
I want to tell them.
And so in a presentation
sense or the presentation setting,
what's called
progressive disclosure.
I'm sure you've all used it.
That's the fancy term for it
if you wanna sound you know,
wonk ish. But you
have a slide. Right?
And you wanna say first
we did this thing,
then we did thing two, then
we did did thing three.
Don't put things two and
things three on the slide.
Only put here's the order we
did. First, we did thing one,
and then tell them
about thing one.
And then make thing two appear
and then talk about thing two
and then make thing three
appear. So even in and I, you
know, fairly neurotypical.
I still have a hard time when
someone clicks that on the
screen, and it goes
one, two, three.
I'm gonna go read They did
one, they did two, they did three.
And then I'm gonna change
my attention back to the speaker.
And so I've now lost everything
they said about thing one,
because I my brain was
focused on the reading part.
It's really hard even for
the best multitaskers above us to
do two things at once. So
making sure you're drawing
that attention both,
in a an orderly way without
giving later information before
you've given it for
first information and then the
earlier information.
And then the second side
is using those emotional and
attention grabbing cues very sparingly.
So did that answer a lot
of that? I hope. Thank you.
That was really helpful.
I see a lot of great
thoughts shared here in the chat too.
Does anybody wanna
jump in and and share what
they put in the chat to?
I don't mean I don't wanna
just Calling someone if you're not
ready to share with a
Ted. I see you unmuted.
So I'll have you jump
in. Yeah. So, I mean,
I discovered this when I I
had, a dyslexic student, and
she was kind enough to explain
to me what she was having
problems with And I think
it's, you know, after kind of
understanding, like,
you know, like,
it's hard to kind of see things
to group things with dyslexia. Like, you know,
that was one of the things
that I thought was especially useful
was using the quarto visual
editor because she would always
kind of cut and paste code
blocks and accidentally copy the back ticks.
And, like, she was wondering
why it wasn't working.
So it's just a
little accessibility thing. So
Definitely. Thank you.
I'm gonna jump oh, I was gonna
just say on on the, like,
the dyslexia component,
there are a lot of really
cool websites out there that show
you approximately what it's like
to read if you have dyslexia,
and those kinda helped me gain
some empathy a long time ago
when I was working with that
with that that population in my
health role. And those were
really helpful. And also
the, font, the typeface design
community spends way too much
time, too much.
It's useful to me.
Thinking about how to put space
in letters and how you can scan
what letters are more
easily scannable.
Some fonts are more easy
to read for dyslexic,
and they've dug
into why you know,
serifs and a fat serif and
how you weight the letters.
And so if you're really
working you know you're working with
that group. There's so
much information on that,
especially in the font and
the typeface situation.
Highly recommend digging into,
You'll see I I use a lot
of roboto because somewhere
someone said that that was
an okay one for scalability,
and reasonably
good for dyslexics.
So That's one I use as a
core component for my for my
the meat of text
when I'm doing that.
So I never have a quarto of
being that, which is brilliant. I love it.
Thank you. Yeah.
I asked him to chat too if
if anybody had recommended
resources for this topic too,
and I see a few suggestions
there. So thank you so much,
Russ, Steven and Damien. Oh,
there's more more
and more coming in.
So I'll make sure to capture
those and put pull them together.
As well.
A a slight question that I
saw come in was Laura, have you
ever experienced a call inflict with
the story you want to tell
and what the data actually
says? Not usually,
because
Let me put it this way.
Many times we we start
with a hypothesis.
We think thing a went
great thing b went bad.
But in the course of
our analysis, we found,
it was the reverse. Right? So
during the analysis, I'm trying to
test my story about what do
I wanna talk about this data?
And for the analysts
in the world, you know,
there's a exploratory
and explanatory data analysis.
Right? And even when
you do explanatory data analysis,
you're still doing a little
bit of exploratory because you're
trying to figure out why a
thing happened and explain why
the thing happened. In
exploratory data analysis,
you're just going,
well, what happened?
So there is a story inherent
in the analysis, and that comes
from a hypothesis.
Right? And oftentimes,
you know, I don't know,
sixty percent of the time.
My initial hypothesis is or
ninety percent of the time,
my initial hypothesis is
not perfectly solid. Right?
I was a little wrong.
We we found something different.
We didn't have the
data to prove ARB.
And so I will talk about that
in my story if I have enough time.
If I only have five minutes
to give a presentation or present
something or it's
only a one pager,
I'm not gonna talk
about that whole thing.
But there are many times
where I've been wrong.
I my story that I thought
at the beginning is not the story
we found at the end, And
depending on your audience,
you might wanna build that in
because if I assumed that it
was thing a at the beginning,
I'm gonna guess most people
in my organization also thought it
was thing a at the beginning.
So you may wanna
start, you know,
clickbait headlines
worked for a reason.
We've all caught wise to it,
but If you thought it was
saying, Hey, boy, do
I have news for you?
Come along on this
journey. And, you know,
that's obviously the a little
bit, not the best lead for
that, but working
with that arc,
especially if you have
the right audience for it,
that might actually cement
your final Actually,
it turned out to
be thing b, better.
Because
everybody in the organization knows it's
thing a. Of course, it's thing a.
We just ask you to go get
the data on we're a data driven
organization. And you're
like, hey, everybody,
we thought it was
a, it really isn't.
And this is why, and I
wanna convince you it's thing b.
And you have to take them on
that journey so that they're with you.
They weren't in that room when
you did forty fifty one hundred
hours of work on the data.
They need to be brought along.
You're you're giving them the
shortened version of that to
get to Finbee. So it's sort of,
you know, I there have
been stories I've wanted to tell,
but from a political situation,
not allowed to tell that story.
So we kinda have to dance
around it a little bit, but usually
the story I want to tell is
the story that we found in the
data. So
and that's kind of
a washy answer, but
Thank you.
I see,
Angeli, and apologies if
I mispronounce your name,
asked about if you had
any internship openings,
but I thought this might be
also a good time to mention as
well. If anybody is
hiring for any roles,
feel free to share them
in the chat as well.
I I forgot to say
that in the beginning.
But Laura wanted to ask
you specifically too. Yeah.
We Let's see how to say
this politically correctly.
Watch our website starting
early in the year.
Some things are
changing in good ways,
and we may or may not
have some positions coming up opening for
data type folks
that watch this space January
Sounds good.
Another slido question
that came in. And
just a reminder,
if anybody joined a
little after the start,
there's a few ways you
can ask questions here.
So feel free to raise
your hand on zoom.
You'll put in the
Zoom chat here.
But we also have the slide
o link that Robert shared where
you can ask anonymously.
But one over there was what are
a few of your go to tools for
storytelling or reporting
with data. Yeah. So
for the me, the person
writing it. I always start
with the I put blank slides for
the number of slides I need and
then I write as the header.
What point do I wanna make
on that slide? Right? We started
high in the organization, we
think thing a. Next slide,
thing a actually turned out
to be false thing that slides.
See, see, the
journey, you know,
we started with this the data
was here and just kind of like
the highlights, you know,
if you if you
take a storytelling course,
it's called the beats
of the story. Right?
So you watch a movie, you
know, I don't know, elf, you know,
baby stolen from home in
Santa's bag. Baby finds out human.
Baby goes to, you know, as
adult goes to city, finds dad,
you know, etcetera, whatever.
So I kind of set my beats
on my slides. Let's
say, or in a document,
I'll just write the sentences that
I want to hit those beats
and make them make them header
and then I go in and okay.
What do I need to tell
that story point? Right?
Well,
I need to tell that this these
three data points that we
usually rely on,
restricted doesn't actually
mean restricted from that
financial code. It actually
means this kind of thing.
So we did this thing.
And then, you know,
kind of build in what do I
need to prove that, prove, support, the underlying
the support for that
that that story be.
And then I'll work my
way through. Oftentimes,
I'm finding myself
writing, like,
forty or fifty words and
I go, too many words,
either I need two beats in
the story or I need an image.
You know, and you
can always, you know,
line went up fifteen
percent. That's an image, obviously.
And there's a lot
of good information,
blog posts at forthcoming,
about how to tell stories.
You can also up story stories
and data, you know, bar
charts, great for context,
like context, contextual, you know,
Categorical. There we go.
Categorical. Right? You wanna say,
we sold more tables than we did
chairs this month or what have you.
You can put changes in there.
There's a whole world of that.
But in those beats, I'll
say I'm trying to prove
month over month,
there were more. Right?
So, you know, I'll go
into the the, you know,
the date of his guru world
and think about, okay,
I wanna show there were
more overtime. How do people use
that? I'll browse around and
look, oh, on, tidy Tuesday,
on the old Twitter was great.
I'm hoping it ends up somewhere.
But I could adventure with
what others were doing to
show that same kind of thing.
And sometimes I'd come
somewhere across a graph and I
go, that tells me that story
when I just look at it.
I don't have to dig in.
Finshall,
I'll steal that information and put
it under my story. B. So,
so in terms of making this
dev developing my whole
talk or my whole document or
my whole whatever I'm giving.
To in terms of my tools
for that are work from a
storyteller's perspective,
work from a
screenwriter's perspective, essentially,
and work with my story beats.
And then from a data
vis perspective,
there's a lot of
information out there,
but my always my number one
thing when it comes to a data
visualization is gonna hold it up
in front of a coworker for
two seconds and
then put it down.
And I want them to tell me
what it was. Line goes up. Line goes
down. Way more of thing a
than the rest of the things.
That's I just want that one, hold
it up on a piece of paper,
move it down. What
do you remember?
And if they don't remember
my salient point, line went up,
line went down, more of thing
a than the rest of the things.
I gotta go back to the
drawing board on that graph. Right?
Leverage maps whenever you can.
You get way more looking at
a map of the United States and
health insurance rights by county
than you do a big old
table of the counties. Right?
So So there's a whole world
on that and digging in is is
kind of that way. I hope
that answers that question.
It's a little fumbly as well,
but I think I got there.
Happy to answer
follow ups needed.
Thank you. Yeah.
The point about maps is just
making me think of last week. I
during Thanksgiving. I saw a map
of the US that said, like,
which states prefer, like,
pecan pie versus apple pie
versus pumpkin pie. And I can
when you said that, I could
just, like, very clearly see
it in my head and remember it.
I see let's see. Alan, you
had a question in the chat. Wanna
jump in here? Yeah. Sure.
This is super fun. I'm just
really, really enjoying it, Laura. Thanks.
I'm wondering so there are
some rooms that don't want the
journey. They want, like,
they want the executive summary,
like, whatever that means.
And I wonder if you've got an
approach or a toolkit or a way
to be informed about what
does this room want and therefore
kind of how to calibrate
it so that you, like,
do the right kind of
preparation and and you come in
with what they're looking for.
And,
you know, if not,
how do you how do you pivot
when you run into that wall when you
you know, when you you start
you start to give the talk,
right, and immediately someone jumps
in and says, you know,
and they just they just wrap
a whole into into something.
I'm wondering how you prepare for
that and how you figure out
how to how to respond. Yep.
So on the first half
prepping for the room. Malcolm Hocker,
CTO Matterist Podcast. He's a
guy who works for a prophecy.
He's worked for Gartner.
I love listening to that
podcast when I run because it's
a it helps me problem solve.
And I I find myself debugging
a lot of code while listening to
but he has this this this
thing he talks about where it says,
if my c suite right
now in my organization,
if I'm developing
something for them,
usually with a request came down
a couple levels to me and
said, hey, they wanna know
this pivot table. I'm like,
they don't wanna
know the pivot table.
They don't want the pivot they
have a business question they're asking.
And they don't know how to
ask down the chain or someone down
the chain doesn't know
how to ask down the chain.
For the spirit of
the information,
so they can only ask
for the letter of the information.
Right? There's a business question.
They don't want the data.
They wanna solve a
business question.
And so Malcolm Hocker says, if you can
get in that room, get in that room.
You're not always gonna be
able to be able to in the room,
but you can ask people
who are in the room,
or you can ask people who
work directly with someone who is in
the room. You know,
there's a a VP and I talk
all the time with one of her her
assistant type people.
And so I always go like, Hey,
what did what did Sarah
Jane want? Sergeant,
what's what's she
working on right now?
I've got a request from her.
Can you give me any
more information on it?
And so leverage that network
back you're never working in a
solo position ever. I hope.
If you're an independent
consultant, you might be,
but hopefully you've given a little
bit of of leverage to at
least ask some people what's going
on and help guide you on
the right track just to see Oh,
they're looking at this
huge project over here.
I don't know much about it,
but it's all about the West Coast.
Whatever. So you
can think, okay.
Let me incorporate that into
my synthesized analysis for them
to make sure I'm hitting the
spirit of the ask rather than
just the letter.
So that's one part.
The other part of the I think
I've got my great story.
I think I've got all my
data and all my story beats ready.
I go into this meeting. And
on slide two, they go, well,
of course, it's thing a.
What about things
c? And I'm like,
I only thought about a and
b. I didn't think about c.
The upside is if you
are the one that did the
exploratory analysis,
You probably saw something related
to it. And I always
hate giving the answer.
I don't know. Because
Sometimes you don't know,
but you kinda have to say
I don't know. But you can say,
oh, well, we there were
some inklings of things see. Here
were, like, we saw this or
we don't collect that data point.
That's why we didn't talk
about it. But we could,
here are some ideas that
I've thought about while drowning in
your data earlier,
or you can kind
of pivot a little,
and this is always why
if I ever give a presentation
that I did not do more than
sixty percent of the work on,
I have that person in the room.
And I have been asked to
present for my team on many,
you know, there's, I know,
five analysts working on something,
and I'm just the one
bringing it all together. I
with every ounce of my fiber
and power, I will have at least
the main analyst in
the meeting with me.
And all the little
side conversation with,
Allison, hey, can you step
in here? Do you got anything?
And I'll also be like,
yeah, cool. And I went,
I'm gonna ask Alison because Alison
did the meat of the work
on the West Coast.
And I'll have Allison come in.
It never works well.
You know, when someone wants
to spin something off the rails,
That's also why at the top
of every presentation I start with
my hypothesis, I start with
the beginning of the story,
which was someone
said, Hey, I'm wondering
how we're doing in California.
You know, so I start
there and I say,
but it was it's only nor it's
only Northern California,
and then that's the path I
took because I don't want them to
think I didn't think about
their hypothesis to start with.
I wanna make sure
that's all in there.
And then the other
thing is in most rooms.
Well, you know,
we only looked at these things
because that was our starting point
there were some information
there. The data wasn't great,
which is why we
pivoted away early.
But let let's talk
about this concept,
and then I'll take your
this conversation right now back to
the drawing board,
and we'll develop that and
give you a follow-up deck or
document or presentation.
It it's led to disappointment
in some meetings I've had back
when I was doing
more consulting type work,
but we never really
had anybody mad.
Sometimes you you're never
gonna get everything.
So I hope that sort of answers.
Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely.
Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you. It was actually
just making me think too about
even, like,
presentations that aren't
like, data related,
but when you're showing
somebody something that you're
really excited to
share them with them,
and then they have great
ideas because they got excited
sometimes I can get distracted
by their great ideas and
wanting to address that in the middle
of the presentation as well. I see
Jeff, you had asked a
question a bit earlier.
Do you wanna jump in here?
And Jeff, I think
it was around, like,
giving five minute talks.
Let me try it. You can jump
in if you wanna add more context.
But the question was Laura,
what what would a five
minute presentation look like
The five minute so I'm gonna
we're gonna go back to my
little fake example here if
we thought saying a in an end
didn't be anything big. Right?
If we're gonna talk in the meat
of it and we're gonna get down
for the analysts,
it's gonna take longer because they're
gonna wanna know every variable. Right?
But if I'm just presenting to this
to the c suite or in my example,
of I have five minutes to get
a minister of health to sign off
on this big spend to fund
my big research study or fund my
program over here.
The the starting point of
that rather than going through the
the beats of my story.
The starting point is what do
I need them to know? What do
they absolutely have to know
when they walk away from this
this five minutes? And
it's thing B was right,
even though we all
assumed it was thing A.
It was I need half a
million dollars because if I don't fund
this, then this big thing
is gonna happen. You know,
I need the thing. I need
you to know this thing.
And if you'd always go back
to that touch point in your five
minutes, then you'll
be successful.
And then with that touch
point, make your little mini story.
Right? You start
with, hey, minister.
I need you to know thing be.
I got five minutes to
convince you. Here's my five minutes.
You know, we all
thought it was thing a.
We did some analysis and I'm
very happy to present you a
longer document we have later,
but the main points were the
data we had to support
thing a was wrong.
When we started
to look into it,
it really turned out to
be thing b even though the
population was smaller.
And then we,
also we're looking at this
other thing and to solve thing,
b, we need this money. And
so rather than I'm writing my
my story beats and
filling in underneath.
It's I'm starting with the
absolutely critical thing that
they need to know. And
then building from there, right,
building the mini
story underneath it.
Everything has to point
back to that salient point.
So It's a, you know, with the
the line, if I'd had more time,
I would have written
a shorter letter.
It's the same thing as it
takes way more work to do five
minutes than it does to
do twenty five minutes.
So plan accordingly.
Awesome. Thank you. Eugene,
I see you had a question.
Wanna jump in here.
Yeah. So
in my experience, I've,
sort of witnessed that
in the modern you know,
last decade and a half of
of just data of becoming the
the reason that people
choose their business actions
or policy actions that everyone
is just becoming a little more
data savvy. And, you
know, the leadership
sort of really starts
to cling to, you know,
data and want to use that
data to support their decision making.
And so
junior analysts or other people
on the team will get blindsided
rather fast sometimes by
the leader that you know,
becomes more and more data savvy.
So they start asking for more slices,
more inter activity so they
can find this stuff out literally
in the meeting, you know,
when when you're presenting this
stuff. So how do you,
help you. What what's your
way of, I think, helping teammates?
Because I I think through
what you're talking about,
it's pretty obvious here.
You're already
doing this yourself.
You're thinking about
this yourself. But,
I think teammates,
yeah, you know,
younger people who who sort
of are looking to that leadership
are are trying to figure out
how to be ahead of those questions.
And I don't think that's an
easy thing for them to get a
grip on until they've been sort
burned, you know, like, ten times.
So I'm just curious if you
have some strategies to keep people
ahead of these, you know,
luddites that on more and more
and more data savvy and start
asking for more and more
complex stuff that that takes
the data analysts
much more time.
Peel apart. Yeah. Absolutely.
So I'm again, as I tend to
do, I split it into two parts.
So I'm gonna start with the
the easier part. Which is,
how to get ahead of the
of the questions you're gonna ask.
So, you know,
let's say I'm a middle person
between a junior and a senior
member and that senior
member is the VP, let's say,
is the one that always asks
way too detailed questions.
I'm gonna make sure I'm working
with that junior member to
know, hey, you know, VP Jane
asks all the details. Right?
She's gonna get in the weeds
with you be prepared to get in
the weeds with her
because she's leading this meeting.
And never just be able
to never respond to Jane.
Always respond to Jane. Okay.
Let's have a conversation,
you know, off of the,
like, sidebar on this.
And let me get into
these details with you,
and we can walk
together through this.
It might not be worth
building a whole dashboard for Jane.
Because really Jane has an idea
on the back of her head that
she's trying to get
out with the well,
I wanna segment it like this.
And Jane doesn't need
to segment it like that.
She's just wondering, like,
what happened to
this group of people.
Right?
So maybe you don't need to build a
dashboard for it to use all that time.
But I've had good experience
with people who are really are
data savvy that they're good with
me live coding with them. Right?
They don't need a whole
dashboard where they can interact.
They're oftentimes okay with me just
doing some live code like, hey,
cut it like this and show
me what that crosstab table looks
like. And they're
they're great with it. So
prepping that junior member
saying Jane asked the questions,
she's gonna want you to go
two steps farther than you did.
So prepare to get ready to
go two steps farther, or
especially if you have a
good relationship, say, Hey, Jane.
Let me you and this junior member
three of us are gonna have a meeting,
and we'll cut this every way
you want in this one hour
shared meeting. I've had
really good results with that,
especially with truly
data savvy people.
The problematic side of this
is, throughout my entire
career, I have worked
with many people who are
data savvy in that they
can use curated products for themselves,
but they cannot use
the chaotic mess.
Right? I am right now in
a chaotic mess of an organization.
It is very hard to rapidly
turn around some results for people
who are like, we're
a big organization.
Why can't I just know how
many constituents we have?
Anybody who's in
data, think about it.
How many constituents do
you have at your organization?
What do you mean?
Finance has a different
definition than does product
sales than does, you know,
the fundraising side, you know,
we've got volunteers as
a as the constituent.
We've got service
members as a constituent.
We've got donors
as a constituent.
We've got congressional
members as constituents.
What is a constituent
at our organization?
That's a hard problem. And it
sounds like it should be easy.
Especially if you've always
been served good data products
that, you know, great
solid data data, enterprise data
level organization.
So that's where I've run into
the problem is where people go,
well, give me all the data.
But they don't know the
context of the data.
They're used to using
a curated data product.
They're they're used to a
working used to the more of a
data scientist role than like
an analytic engineer role.
Right? They came up
through the data science,
but they don't know how all
this controllful processes work
and why it doesn't
talk to each other.
That's where I've struggled.
And if anybody has
good ideas on that one,
because you can't
exactly tell your CEO.
No. No. You don't
understand what you're talking about.
You have to answer that CEO's
question as best you can
without giving him here's twenty
two million rows of data.
Have at it, mister CEO. I
don't know what to tell you,
because you'll go
a little crazy.
And you'd also don't
wanna spend you know,
hundreds of analysts and dev
hours building a dashboard for
something when he only
wanted that one question,
or he's never gonna use it.
Gonna go to the the
graveyard of dashboards.
So if anybody has any good
ideas on those folks that are
genuinely good hearted
and best intentions,
it's just they're only used
to working with beautiful data
products, anyone? Anyone.
I'll walk I'll watch for
unmutes to see if anyone he
wants to jump in on this.
That I saw,
fill up with you.
I was gonna quickly say
you could scare them with,
the rough you know, console us,
font output of a table,
table function that you
run-in r and just snapshot,
drop it to them,
scare them Yeah.
A little bit of a red
flag. Back off. I know what I'm
doing. Tell me your business
problem, and I'll help you,
but just give me
data and then yeah.
Bila, I I see you had a,
like, a follow along
question to
Eugene's question and just wanted
to make sure we cover
that in the the answer to.
And I heard somebody
was about to jump in.
So I'll have you jump in first,
and then we'll we'll
jump over there then.
I was just saying that
I've I've run-in some folks that
were more of.
Let's just I why don't you look
at the data as a data scientist
and you tell me what our
problem should be that we're solving.
One part lucky and one
part me at my pain level?
You don't need to play the
strategy of the org? I mean,
cool. But You get the well,
you're good at looking at
things and understanding how
data, you know, getting
answers from data.
You should be able to also
come up with the questions.
But that's something I've
run into with with certain
executives where that that's
that's one that's you it
there's nuances to
navigating that.
And now I'm curious. What
how do you navigate that?
I'd go back to I need to
understand what we're trying to
accomplish because the, you know,
that's that's the lens through
which I will view the data.
And without that, It's
all just blurry to me.
It also sounds like you've been
cursed by being good at your job.
I've I've also got twenty seven
years in the same industry.
So the I also I have a fair
amount of a domain knowledge, so that's where
the that's where that's
coming in. Really? Yeah.
I think this may have been
addressed a bit in the answer,
but I saw Philip had said cool
question, Eugene,
so added on to it.
And said we get a lot of
workshop like meetings where
you get a broad question
thrown at you and doing the
explorations and the
meeting with management,
how would you prepare or
anticipate for that type of
meeting? Anything you
wanna add to that? Yeah.
Just the way I've
done it is, you know,
make sure you've got
all your, you know,
if you're small
world non enterprise,
make sure it's all on your
desktop and your environment. Ready to go,
make sure you've got it
pushed to something like a parquet
file that's really
rapidly pivotable,
especially if you've
got big, big data sets.
You know, if you're lucky
to work in, you know,
we work in Databricks,
we've got a unity catalog,
so I can go connect to
everything that I have permission for.
I also have a great partnership with
IT so I know what date is available.
If I have a reason to ask
for it. And so if I'm in that
meeting and they go, well,
what about the volunteers? Oh, well,
if you'd like that,
just send me an email and we'll
get the IT to approve my my
need for that. But, you know,
because we have, you know,
security permissions and
siloed, siloed, siloed,
I haven't had access
to that. So really
those those types of meetings,
and I've had several of them.
Like, my example
with, you know, Jane,
the VP and a junior member,
live coding just like
slash it this way.
It's been,
like, make sure
that your, you know,
digital desktop of
all of your things,
everything's within
reach of you.
To be ready to go.
And then you'll you're both
gonna do your best to answer
that VP, that VP
Jane's questions.
But also you're gonna be seen
as someone who can get stuff
done really quickly. And so
questions might come out of that,
that
help you do the
rest of your job.
So I those are
stressful hard hours.
They're really hard and you have
to be quick and on your
toes. And know everything's right
there. You can just grab it.
You know, I can just
grab, you know, whatever,
my hair tie or
whatever. I can grab it.
And then serve the
information quickly.
And if I can't totally serve
the information quickly,
we have that question,
that hypothesis that we
know Jane is curious about.
And so those are so tough and if
you get it to go into one of
those, it's probably gonna be
really hard and really, really
useful. So any chance you
have for one of those grab it.
If you don't have Tim's twenty
seven years in the business and
know a lot of it already,
if you're in that one, well,
I think you've got this twenty
seven years of experience,
I think you've got a little bit of a
a leg up on some of that. Thank you.
I see. Let's see.
Sir, I see you asked a
question in the chat.
I'll read it because I
see the little star here.
But the question was,
I work in academic
research as a grad student,
and I often have trouble
telling a story because it
takes so long to get
people the scientific background they need
to actually care about the
problem we are solving computationally.
Any advice on keeping the
background engaging or working
it into the story
along with the data?
Take the time. Take your
time and practice on your friends.
My sister heard four hundred
versions of my doctoral
dissertation presentation
conservatively,
because I kept testing messages
on her and she understood
virtually nothing of what I
actually did. By the end of it,
she understood a lot
of it, but not a lot.
The but that that idea of
that background is huge
to get to. We went here.
Always then then
that's part of, like,
where I have the story What do
I need them to know as we go
along? On this slide,
I need to take two minutes
to make sure they know
Jean ABC four is critical
in these eleven diseases.
Right? Do I need them to
know ABC four up regulates
this and down regulates this?
But when it down
regulates this,
it then upregulates these two other
things. Do I need them to
know that it down and
upregulates all of these
certain things? Maybe not.
Maybe I just need them to know
that ABC does is is involved in
some way in these
nine conditions.
If you need to talk about
each way of those conditions because
it has an impact later. Right?
Maybe it's these five
conditions, it's an up
regulator, and these three these
three, it's a down regulator.
That's that critical component.
And later when we're
talking about our analysis,
we found it affected only
down regulators, not up regulators. Well,
then you need to spend a
little more time on that touch point.
But building from a story beat
and everything within that
story beat of
service of that beat.
Is a good is a good way
to tie it back. And then, of course,
practice on someone who
doesn't know anything.
Find your best friend who works
in She's a finance person and
you're a geneticist.
Tell your finance friend about it
and see if she can follow
the story even though she
doesn't have the detail. Right?
And then get your lab partner,
you know, and say, hey,
lab partner, when I
tell you the story,
does it remain faithful
to the extreme detail?
Cause there's always
gonna be an abstraction.
There was a great, when
all the Posit talks are up,
there was a great, talk
about leaky obstructions,
one of the keynotes, I think.
Wonderful.
Talk. Go pay attention
to that talk.
But I always now I'm trying
to pay attention to where my
abstracts might my
abstractions might be leaky.
And give a little note.
Maybe it's just a
little footnote of just, hey,
there's a thing. You
might wanna pay attention.
This is a generalization.
But up regulator,
down regulator,
and this is where the changes.
There's some down regulation in
these. Do they need to know?
Maybe not So it's sort
of go back to that,
make sure you're hitting
your touch points.
And if if it's the five minute,
it's in service of
that key message,
if it's the longer presentation
of your story beats.
Thank you.
I,
I don't always get to read
the chat while the hangouts are
happening that I just
wanted to remind people,
you can save the chat because
they see there's a lot of great
resources being shared in
there. There's that little,
three dots at the bottom. Of
the chat where you can save it.
But I was laughing at these
office jargon phrases that you all are,
office jargon that
you're all sharing there,
like boiling the ocean and
all the low hanging fruit.
There's there's
quite a few in there.
Ethan, I I see you asked a
question a bit earlier in the
chat. Do you wanna jump
in here? Yeah. Sure.
Laura,
I was just curious if you're
if you're giving like a slide
slide deck presentation
to what extent do you utilize
an appendix or you have slides
on details, although that's details
you feel like you have to
present to validate some of
the stuff you're doing or the
points you're making or
just questions you anticipate to
what extent do you utilize
that, or do you try to keep the
presentation really,
really clean and save all that
stuff for just if there's a
follow-up question on it.
I always have extra
slides because, again,
my original presentations are always
like an hour and a half.
So as I'm building
I wanna put my gene example,
you know, here's the gene ABC.
It's in these five
and these three.
I'm gonna wanna tell you four
hundred things about all of these things.
All eight of these,
I'm gonna wanna tell you it
does it's mostly a down regular,
but it does these nine nine
other and this one actually is
involved in this thing,
but not these things
and sometimes only in men,
but not usually whatever.
I'm gonna wanna tell you a
lot of stuff about these eight.
Right? And so when I
build my original talk,
I'm gonna overbuild that slide.
And then when I go back through
my cleaning round, again,
if I had more time. I
would have written a shorter letter.
I'll go back again and say,
okay. I have six slides for this.
These saying ABC is
related to these eight.
What in here doesn't go back to
that touch point of I need you
to know ABC is involved in
a lot that continues the rest of
my story. And I'll have a
slide on each of these eight things.
All of those go
into the appendix.
All of those are for later
slides because someone in that
room, to someone's
point earlier,
might wanna try and
throw me off. Well,
you didn't consider that thing
that second thing is that
really, you said
it's an up regulator,
but it down regulates
these four hundred other things.
Well, hey, mister,
you know, guy.
Here's here's the slide that shows
why I'm putting it in the
up regulator category. Right?
So when mister snoody guy wants
to throw you under the bus,
you've got those slides. We
can go mister snoody guy.
We we this is why I
put it over there.
Super happy to have more
conversations with you about
this, but really we're here to
talk about the whatever I said,
that's down regulating three,
and that's why it
got put up here.
So I use them all the
time and usually because
I started way too long
and they got pulled back.
I will make sure some of
that might be really, really needed,
right, to tell the whole story.
Some of that thing about
thing too being an up and down
whatever I made up that might
be really critical to the rest
of the story of why it went
up here and not over here. Right?
So I need to include
that information because it's in
service to that story
point I need to tell.
So it might stay in and
then I have to shorten another ten
minutes somewhere
in that speech,
I'm gonna have to
drop some information.
But if you're only given
ten minutes to talk,
you absolutely cannot tell the
full story of an entire gene.
It's not gonna happen. Right?
No chance They didn't
give me enough time.
So going back to the what do
they need to know and what are
the story boards story points
to get there, service of that,
and then you've got that extra
stuff that you had to cut out
cut to size in your appendix.
I may or may not cut those
appendix slides out if I have
to share, like, great. I want
your slides. I might not include those.
If it's a recorded talk and
we talked about that second thing,
I'll put that slide in at
the end so that if they're watching
a video, they can
see that slide.
Or if we wanna talk
more about that slide,
I'll put it in the middle,
and then we can have that
can spur more conversations.
But I almost always have extra stuff
that just made my talk too long.
I can't believe how fast this
hour is going by right now.
But I I know I said in the
beginning here that I love in
the in the hangouts where we
get to kinda just get, like,
a little snippet into what life
is like is that data scientists
in different industries. And
I was just curious if you
could share, like, a high
level project that you may
work on in your role,
not without going into, like,
specifics, of course,
but just kinda giving us
a glimpse into do it? Yeah.
So because I'm on the
development operation side, the, like,
the number one thing is where did
we get our money and from who?
And are there, you know,
we have managed donors, you know,
joe billionaire is gonna have
a special fundraiser assigned to them.
But if you're just giving us two
hundred dollars at the end of the year,
get a nice thank you and
maybe a Christmas ornament,
but we're not we don't
have a person managing you, right,
to make sure that we
have a good relationship.
This is the same through
all any nonprofit that does
fundraising, it's the
same kind of idea.
But there's also that middle
group of people of, well,
maybe they're writing us three
thousand dollar checks every year.
Should we put them in the
should we give him a fundraiser
or maybe not? Or this guy
only gives us twenty five dollars
a month. You know,
this lady gives us twenty five
dollars a month every month and
has for ten years But our
wealth rating says she's got a
lot of money in the bank,
and she seems to be
eighty two years old.
Maybe we should talk
to her about a bequest.
Let's put a person on her
even though she's a small giver.
So broadly, my reports
fall into like three categories.
Like, How are we raising
money? And that might be a big,
you know, quarterly report or,
something to go into
a grant application.
And then how are our
fundraisers doing with their portfolios?
And then what about these
middle people that maybe we
should have a guy
on? Can you go, like,
dig into that middle slice
the middle demographic and find us
some people that maybe want to
check out and do some research
on. So it kind of
falls into those three.
And I generally am only
reporting in the fundraising
the fundraiser space. I don't
do a whole lot on, like,
the how many people clicked
on this Instagram ad?
Versus the dog Instagram
ad versus the veterans day
Instagram ad.
We have another team that
does that kind of the direct
response kind of stuff.
We I work in the
fundraising world. So bringing lots of
stuff, weird stuff together
and saying is this person,
is this John Smith the
same as that John Smith?
We do lots of the
Smith problem,
which I'm sure anybody's taken
a data set classes, done that,
and also set your hair on
fire for how many constituents do we
have? I don't know.
Are these eighty four
people the same John Smith?
Your guess is as good as
mine. So a lot of that world.
Great. Thank you
so much, Laura.
I I see there's a
few questions that,
we might not get to. I just
saw a few from the the chat,
but I just wanted to
give everybody the opportunity. Like,
we have a few minutes left
if you wanna raise your hand here
if there was a question that
we didn't get two of yours.
And I'll just keep an eye out
while I ask this one I see.
Joseph asked and put a little
star there so I'll read it.
I have a team member who
wants to add tool tips to everything.
But I worry that some audiences
are overwhelmed by those
details or that adding those
options makes some people dive
deep too quickly without seeing
the big picture in the visualization.
Do you have a way of thinking
about when tool tips or a table
view are useful and when
they're distracting?
Yeah. That's always the
a lot of the times I
go, we should, but we shouldn't,
and I fight myself
into a circle.
And then at the end of the day,
The highest title in the room
is the one that decides whether
or not we have them. If
the CEO wants all of them,
they're going in.
I spend some time maybe designing
that tool tip so that it's
less intrusive or it's
easier to scan. And again,
in product design
worlds, you know,
there's lots of talk about
how the nutrient label on food.
How scannable is that?
How does that that's a
tooltip on a physical product.
Right?
So I spend some time designing
how that tool tip might pop up.
But if the, you know, the
CEO wants it, it's happening.
If a low level analyst wants it
or not a low level but down the
chain analyst and this is
being delivered to everybody,
maybe I turn it off
for everybody, but offer you know,
packaged version to that
analyst who really wants to do
some exploration.
If I can get the, you know,
the space on all of our servers,
I'll have two versions
of that dashboard.
The executive version
and the analyst version.
And so sometimes, you know,
the CEO wants this is what
you get shared at unless you ask
too many questions,
then we give you this one
which hopefully spurs more questions. So
it almost ends up as
the highest title in the room.
And then if I have fellow
curious data people that I try
and serve them because they're
trying to answer questions too
or find more questions.
So kind of a a lucy
Washington answer on that one,
but Sometimes
that's what it is.
Thank you so much, Laura.
As we get to the end here,
I'm just wondering if people
wanna connect with you,
what's the best way? Is it
LinkedIn or through your blog? Or
yeah, LinkedIn or I'm on threads,
but my threads is kind of
not professional, but I feel like
this is not professional. You know,
this is fun nerds making
jokes about bad product design. So
LinkedIn's the best,
the easiest place
in a professional capacity.
Awesome. I did
just wanna share.
We do have a data
science hangout community LinkedIn group.
Maybe sometimes not the best
way to have back and forth
conversation, but we try
sometimes. But I shared it in
the chat there if anybody wants
to join that group to make it
easier to connect with
each other as well.
I love getting to hear
about People who are friends now
because they met in the
data science hangout or maybe met
each other, yeah, in the
chat, sharing resources.
But thank you so much Laura
for joining us today and and
sharing your experience. This
has been so fun. Absolutely.
Thank you, everyone.
And I'm very open to
questions on LinkedIn.
Just just send me questions.
Awesome. Well, thank you all. Have
a great rest of the day.
So nice to see you.
Bye everyone. Bye.